tiens monsieur le président
le premier président
j'ouvrirai
de l'endettement public qui avec la
remontée de l'inflation reprend reprend
toute sa place
dans cette instance on est tous d'accord
pour se dire que la dette doivent faire
l'objet d'un remboursement et il serait
absolument pas raisonnable de s'y
soustraire
néanmoins ce qui est souhaiterait
recueillir votre avis sur les parcs
contributives de chacun dans ce
remboursement
dans l'histoire récente le premier
réflexe a été d'exiger immédiatement des
économies et des réformes notamment
celle des retraites c'est ce qu'a fait
madame la première ministre le 6 juillet
vous lui avaient emboîté le poids le 8 /
sur une grande radio nationale ce que
vous confirmez ce matin j'ai le
sentiment que ce réflexe depuis sa
source dans des modèles existants et que
je qualifierais de peu efficient et
notamment je m'interroge sur l'échec des
politiques passées si le ratio dette
publique sur pib ne revient pas à son
niveau d'avant crise c'est parce que les
fonds utilisés ne permettent pas d'
accélérer suffisamment l'activité il y a
une propension à se concentrer
principalement sur les politiques
sociales et ce pour une raison simple
ces dépenses sont parfaitement documenté
et incontrôlée notamment via les pn fss
les économies elles sont d'abord sur les
cotisations sociales ça a été rappelé ce
matin ensuite sur les impôts eux mêmes
sur le dernier quinquennat le taux de
l'impôt sur les sociétés est passé 33 3
% à 25 % soit 15 milliards d'euros par
an dans le même temps une partie des
impôts de production pour 10 milliards
d'euros a été réduite la suppression
annoncée de la tva qui sera effectif dès
2023 coûtera aux finances publiques près
de 8 milliards d'euros s'ajoutant ainsi
à la longue longue liste des aides
venant conforter la politique de l'offre
et donc même ma question monsieur le
président premier président est la
suivante est ce que vous ne pensez pas
que les baisses systématique des impôts
sur le capital
contribuer à grévé la faculté de
remboursement de la dette publique